Michelle and I want to send our best wishes to everyone celebrating the Lunar New Year,...
...including Asian-Americans and Pacific Islanders.
You know, growing up in Hawaii, I remember all the excitement surrounding the Lunar New Year;...
...from the parades and the fireworks, to the smaller gatherings with family and friends.
It's always been a time for celebration and for hope.
And this year, as Americans here at home and around the world welcome the Year of the Dragon,...
...it's important to remember that our country is stronger because of our diversity.
We're richer because of the different cultures that make up this country.
So to all those celebrating the Lunar New Year,...
...I wish you and your loved ones peace, prosperity and good health.